if you don't mind angela maybe
maybe take a moment and tell us what's
been happening with you in your
restaurant in the last week or two
um well in the last week here in
california um
they've just been doing more and more
lockdowns so
two days before thanksgiving we got
noticed that all
outdoor dining which we worked very hard
to do
and put up spend about 60 to 80 000
doing all the changes over the last year
that they wanted
was going to be shut down the night
before thanksgiving
and you know basically i had to let my
staff
know that they didn't have a job for the
holidays because we can't sustain with
to go
to go is about 10 we make gross about 10
percent and we lose about 90
profit and anybody knows anything about
a brick and mortar business
and a restaurant the margins are very
thin and the costs are very high
i tried to stay open uh the first time
around for to go
for my customers and also for the
community because the community
really missed you and in la we have a
lot of people that are older and alone
or they're living alone because they've
moved here and all their families out of
state so connection
and community is very very vital to them
so they did come out for to go
and it broke my heart but i didn't have
enough money to sustain this time
so i had to shut down completely now
when for for people to understand
running a business
how many employees do you have your
employees one day when that when you
shut down
are they getting any kind of a comp
money from the state is this
oh my god tell us the details
behind it well i wish this
restaurant was in indiana or michigan
because in la you know we
are at a gradual climb up to 15 an hour
the expenses are very high here the
rents are very high
we were already losing businesses to the
minimum wage hike
many of my other competitors and
friends were closing because of the
minimum wage hike
so when this went down um no uh
unemployment's all they had you know
they could rely on and then i was lucky
enough to get the ppp
loan but the ppp loan only lasts for two
and a half months mind you
i got a hundred thousand dollars i have
15 employees um
pre pandemic and um
basically that's roughly you know my
payroll is roughly 25 to 30 000 a month
and and so between rent and that it
lasted two and a half months
and we weren't actually allowed to be
fully open either so i kind of did
stretch
that you know because i i once we went
to to go i basically went down to four
four employees from 15.
from 15 to four employees and these are
in a small business everybody works like
a family and when you're 15 employees
everybody knows each other especially
restaurant you're talking to each other
you don't call a boss it's just
friendship relationship that there's
there
what did these 11 employees of yours
slash
friends of yours are you working with
what did they how how would they paying
a price for you having to let them go
oh i have a cat just just a little
history of my
my pub it's been here since 1978 it's
one of the few holdovers of
the cheers bars on the third owner
the kitchen staff has been there
since 1978. wow and they
are a brother george um who works the
day shift
miguel works at night and runs the
kitchen does the grocery shopping and
the cleaning
his wife does dishes and buses and now
his son has come in
um so my entire kitchen
their household their entire household
depends on
me solely they've never had another job
since 1978. now my front house
i had yeah i had my front house i had
staff that had been with me since day
one i've had it 10 years so
i had a bartender that been with me 10
years that i lost through this
you know because he had to go and try to
find other means of work and
you know i had some that i was able to
keep um
but yeah i mean they have to find other
work and if they can't find other work
they got to rely on unemployment
i can't afford to pay them to stay at
home i don't have that kind of extra
funds
so here's a question for you did it
create any kind of friction between you
and them because a lot of times
situations like this
what they do is they're they could say
well angela you don't understand the
situation i'm going through it's my wife
i've been there since 78 and i have a
son am i
you know we're running this thing
together you know you got to can you
help us out and you want to help them
out you can't help them out
did it cost any friction between you and
your employees
you know it didn't i will say um in the
beginning
um you know miguel who runs my kitchen
the other caveat with with
my um with miguel and his wife who run
my kitchen is
is they were here in a work visa for
many years and they had just
applied for their citizenship in
february
and had gotten it and they were waiting
for the paperwork but then the paperwork
got postponed
and he was terrified to apply for
unemployment even though he's been
paying in the system forever
because he's afraid until he got that
actual certificate in his hand
he was afraid to take money from the
government
so for me his brother
george was able to get unemployment
and i paid him out of what funds i had
to keep him going and then luckily the
ppp what
really i stayed open as an essential
business
and i employed him and um i did to go
and i was bleeding about 30 000 a month
um
loss staying open for to go but
you know i had to keep them employed i
mean what are they going to do that's
right what are they going to do you know
what i mean
oh no question you see sometimes uh when
uh
you look at the media sometimes they
portray business owners as being these
rich greedy people that all they care
about is themselves
but they don't see the story behind
closed doors where
folks have stayed with the same place
since 1978
and a family four people have a job from
the same family
working for you i think what i'd like to
do is i like the audience
to see which video was that was viral
and uh
you know david maybe this will kind of
give you an idea what story she was
selling and then i want to kind of share
with everybody else the audience that
hasn't seen
what mayor garcetti had to say about
your video
here's the video
so this is my place the pineapple hill
grill and saloon if you go to my page
you can see all the work i did
for outdoor dining for tables being
seven feet apart
and i come in today because i'm
organizing a protest and
i came in to get stuff for that
and i walk into my parking lot and
obviously mayor garcetti has approved
[Music]
this
has approved
this being set up for this
being set up for for a movie company
i'm losing everything everything i own
is being taken away from me
and they set up a movie company right
next
to my outdoor patio which is right over
here
and people wonder why i'm protesting
and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot survive
my staff cannot survive look at this
tell me that this is dangerous
but right next to me is a slap in my
face
that's safe this is safe
50 feet away
this is dangerous mayor garcetti and
gavin newsom
is responsible for every single person
that doesn't have unemployment that does
not have a job
and all the businesses that are going
under and we need your help
we need somebody to do something about
this
david what's your reaction when you see
that video right there with angela
hey that's bringing tears to my eyes
that bothers me tremendously okay
um that is heart wrenching and i'm sorry
that bothers me
but you know what you know what's
intense i want to read this to everybody
that's watching this mayor garcetti
responded and he gave a statement
before i read this statement this is
what's going on with california
california has declared
the entertainment industry workers
essential that's what was going on 50
feet away from where you were at and in
l.a county they must follow strict
guidelines
such as eating and staggered shifts or
in an area large enough to stay
six feet apart restrictions la county is
shutting down all dining at restaurants
breweries wineries and bars
for at least three weeks starting
wednesday november 25th which is which
was two weeks ago amid a surge in
coronavirus cases
health official announced sunday and
mayor garcetti said
my heart goes out to miss marston
and the workers at the pineapple hill
saloon who have to comply with the state
and county public health
restrictions that close outdoor dining
no one likes these restrictions but i do
support them
as our hospital icu bed filled to
capacity and cases have increased by 500
we must stop this virus
before it kills thousands of more
angelenos angel
angela what do you have to say with what
mayor garcetti had to say to you i'm out
i'm i'm outraged you know i
since then we've we i've made some
progress and we just run we just won
um with a judge in the la courts and the
judge ruled in our favor and said
that it was arbitrary it was it was
not backed by science but you know
what i need why what i like to say to
him and what i have already said
is do not sit and tell me
that there are stay-at-home orders
because that is
not real there is 50 of us
out here that cannot stay at home and
work off zoom
and and work off tech or have rich
families
so when you say we're in this together
and you say oh
you know you can stay at home you're
you're lying
that is not an option you know you're
making people choose between
having a place to live and eat
or or not like this is life-and-death
situation
you know this is evictions this is not
no food forget the fact that i have
children i have
employees with children that have no
money now for christmas
they can't they're wondering what
they're going to get how they're going
to get through even christmas let alone
paying the rent my manager was crying
her unemployment is done it's up and
there's no
we don't know they have come up with
nothing they're on vacation right now
there's no emergency session for us to
get our you know ppp or
unemployment and and it's ridiculous
it's absolutely
ridiculous it is are you open now are
you open right now or no
no i am i will say that through this
we've been blessed we've had a lot of
donations
and um i have been sticking with what i
said in the beginning which is i will
not stop
until they let us open and i'm speaking
on behalf of all
small businesses here now um but i'm
hoping um
friday that i'll be able to go over some
numbers now and with the help i mean
i've gotten support from all over the
world i had
amaze the most amazing like thing
happened um
uh brooks burgers in florida they own uh
three hamburger uh places there
called me and said i wanna i wanna
support you from over the pond because
we don't need the government to take
care of us we can take care of
each other and he offered to pay a month
worth of rent
and that's another restaurants here in a
state that's open
powerful i mean i i was crying he
i mean just today he called and he said
you know i decided
you know my rent's like 10 000. so he
said i'm going to send you 5000 right
away
and this this really obviously triggered
me and he said
i think we're going to do a take the
rest and have the customers do
like we'll do a celebration and a
fundraiser and have them match it so we
can get you more money
i could not stop crying because when i
had my bar
every christmas i did bad santa
christmas
and it would be a fundraiser and i would
raise funds for
the orphanages and for the other
community and then now i'm in this
situation
and the kindness of this person it was
it was
i don't have words to explain the
generosity
the humanity the kindness and outpour
and and i'm just
great to see great to see because other
restaurant owners and business owners
obviously know the challenges you guys
are going through you know there's a
community and and the benefit
the the restaurant owner in florida has
over you is
the desantis's regulations in florida
are very different than newsom's
regulations in the state of california
has this event at all influenced you to
consider moving to another state
um you know honestly um right before
this happened i'm from indiana
all my family's there and um my mom said
angela
just throw in the towel come back home
live with us
open a place here and
i couldn't i sat and i thought about i
said mom and you know
my mom worked in a bread factory she's a
very determined woman woman
so i i called her i said mom i've been
in la
28 years this is my town and people are
fleeing out of it and nobody is doing
anything about it and i said
i can't just leave i have to finally
start
telling the truth and showing people
what's going on
instead of keeping it in you know it's
it i just can't
i can't i have five bar owner friends
who haven't been able to open for nine
months because they don't have food they
don't have food in their establishment
they one of them has gone through their
life savings and their unemployment's
almost
up the other one is took out a personal
loan neither of them got ppps
the other one has two bars she'd just
gotten her second one a year ago
they're done i mean we are losing we
lost 110
000 restaurants and that was before this
closure
so i can't just leave i can't i got to
do
something i have to move the giant
because somebody's got to stand up
for this community you know well more
power to you just so you know there's a
lot of people in the state of california
that would like
more folks like yourself to be vocal
because sometimes people can't speak for
themselves and it's great to see
your video going viral on twitter
getting 9.2 million views
the challenge is i mean on gofundme you
know thank god there's a product like
gofundme
invented by capitalist that allows times
like this for people to take advantage
of it i believe you've been able to
raise
183 thousand dollars we're going to put
the link below as well which just tells
you how much support you have
but i wonder for the other business
owners that have lost their restaurants
who couldn't get a video to go viral or
somehow somebody
didn't go their way they have to shut
down and those 15 employees are lost